i'm trevor phillips this is common
ground where each week we look for
agreement on a hot button issue dividing
the nation
we don't want to see any
kid any family going hungry in this
country we have parents turning up here
in tears
literally they will have fed the
children and put them to bed they won't
have eaten themselves
we've got generation after generation
who cannot cook properly they can't cook
a meal from scratch they cannot budget
and i'm going to continue that diet
because you've got to search for the
hero inside yourself in the hope that
individual is considerably slimmer
i ask you
dare i say i beg you
please reconsider backtracking
on key parts of the childhood obesity
strategy
apocalypse now says the boss of the bank
of england inflation and war are
triggering the food crisis
sky news reports that one in four of us
is missing a meal each day
but what about the war on obesity say
food campaigners which could save the
nhs billions from the cost of unhealthy
eating
and until now they thought that the
government was on their side ready to
ban cheap food deals
but faced with a cost of living spiral
ministers still want you to bog off buy
one get one free a former tory leader
today called the move morally
reprehensible our choice
should good government shepherd us
towards what it thinks are the right
food choices or should the war on junk
food take a back seat to cutting the
cost of living
in the next half hour two passionate
believers come head to head in the
search for common ground
[Music]
with me tonight the cook food writer and
campaigner thomasina myers and
christopher snowden head of lifestyle
economics at the institute of economic
affairs
chris um let me start with you we are
the fattest nation in europe i think
isn't it morally represented
reprehensible as lord hague puts it for
government to encourage harmful eating
for a short term
fix to the cost of living crisis i think
malta is still a bit fatter than us
technically speaking but um uh well i
mean look i think a lot of this comes
down to evidence-based policy and what
we tend to do in this country on this
issue is say well there's lots of fat
people it's terrible
and therefore let's come up with some
ideas and we'll just implement them
whereas i think we should be looking at
each policy individually and saying what
good is this going to do is this going
to do what are the unintended
consequences what's what is it going to
cost now there are impact assessments
for these policies this bog off ban for
example is estimated in the impact
assessment to reduce calorie intake by
an average of eight calories per person
per day it's a very very trivial amount
it is also estimated to have a
cost i'm not quite sure what the cost is
going to be and these impact assessments
are largely guesswork but if you take
something like a meal deal which are
very very popular millions of people
every lunchtime go out for a meal deal
if you have to buy those items
individually it's going to cost
significantly more than it does three
pound for it for a meal deal and when we
talk about junk food we need to remember
that it includes things like a ham and
cheese sandwich okay it's not actually
junk food and i think the media have
been complicit with some of the
campaigners and using this pejorative
term which makes people think of a
handful of american fast food chains
when actually it includes things like
raisins and butter and pasta so you get
yourself a chicken and bacon sandwich
even if you have a healthy side and a
bottle of water with it that is going to
be banned because it's junk food
supposedly now that has a significant
cost for millions of people but people
don't really think it through we haven't
not thought it through we've not had a
serious debate about any of these things
you should believe that on balance the
the the the harm is greater than the
pretty trivial benefits are you sure
it's just it's evidence-based or is it
just you don't like want to be told what
to do
i don't like being told what to do but i
accept being told what to do as
everybody does in civilized society
because there's reasons to have laws and
regulations so there's lots of things
i'd maybe quite like to do in a state of
nature that i don't do because i
understand that there's a purpose to
them and they're valuable i don't think
any of this anti beastie stuff is
all right thomasine um
we are
in a situation where people are missing
meals every day and
because they can't afford them why
shouldn't government at least for the
time being
just let people buy food that is cheap
that will
uh take no time to prepare so they can
get on with work
i think
i mean we are in an epidemic it's
costing the nhs 18 billion pounds a year
to uh diet-related disease which could
be going towards
subsidizing fresh fruit vegetables which
is what people on low incomes can't
afford not only can't they afford them
but it's very hard for them to get
access to them they live in food deserts
they live next to convenience stores um
to fast food outlets so it's really hot
especially the moms who've got you know
double jobs you can't cook in the
evening as you say
i'm not sure this
stops
that problem uh what this does is help
stop you know the bug-off which which a
lot of it is junk food and when i say
junk food i'm not talking about ham
cheese sandwich i'm talking about ultra
processed food which we know is killing
people i mean diet-related disease now
kills more people than than smoking or
alcohol and i kind of think it's a
scandal that in a western country where
we should know better we're allowing
companies who profit on the backs of
making lives people's lives miserable
and it's people on low incomes who often
don't have the choice and and i guess
what i'm saying is if i'm a mum in
liverpool my
life expectancy is 11 years less than
her neighbor in a more affluent part of
liverpool so basically she might have
never get to meet her grandchildren
because 11 years she's got less on her
life her children are twice as likely to
be obese this is adversely affecting
people on low incomes and and the whole
legislation which boris put in he made
law is trying to help people like that
get on to better food i mean everyone
loves
some junk you know i eat boosts or like
kettle chips or like ben and jerry we
all like fun food like that it's just
not when it's half of your diet okay um
other crisps and ice creams are
available um
chris uh
as tommy's pointed out the cost of
obesity estimated to be at least
18 billion pounds a year half the
defense budget 400 pounds per household
some somebody reckons isn't it part of
um
the duty of government uh and part of
our duty to our fellow citizens uh to
reduce that cost in the way that uh
thomas has been talking about and part
of the government's business to make
sure that we reduce those costs i think
there are two answers to that the first
is that i don't think it was part of the
deal in 1948 when the nhs was founded
that we're going to get health care free
at the point of use but there's a whole
list of footnotes and caveats and uh
structures saying that this only applies
if you don't smoke and you lose weight
and you only eat this and you don't
drink too much and i think if that was a
deal in 1948 but people would have said
no you can stick the nhs we'll stick
with private healthcare the second
answer is that actually if you look at
the economics if it doesn't stack up
this idea that the taxpayer uh you know
the individual
non-obese taxpayers are having to
subsidize fat people's health care is is
not true it wasn't true when they said
about smoking it's not true when they
say about obesity for a rather macabre
reason but we shouldn't bury our heads
in the sand about this which is that if
you have
lifestyle related diseases that kill
people 10 years early whatever it may be
they are not taking out a pension for 10
years they are not having health care
during those 10 years they're not having
hip replacements and cataracts and so on
and actually most of the health budget
is spent on old people and all people's
problems
come on but we are spending money on
keeping people alive uh with health
related smoking-related diseases
the the consequences of obesity i think
that uh it's now reckoned that we spend
more on type 2 diabetes than we do on
cancer
and if they didn't have these what you
call lifestyle-related diseases would
they not require any health care no they
would live longer and actually require
more health care in the end there's a
lot of economic evidence on this
actually the smokers cost the lease
obese people cost a bit less and people
who don't smoke in a slim cost the most
over the course of a lifetime and they
cost most of that money when they're
retired they're not paying much into the
system they're mostly taking out now
that that could easily be misconstrued
that argument because i've made this
argument before because people would
then say oh you want to kill off people
so try and be be efficient no i'm not
saying so to be clear we're not for
killing
people we're not going to encourage
people to smoke and get fat because it
will save the taxpayer money but it will
save the taxpayer money and if you're
going to use the economic argument to
try and justify paternalistic regulation
it's only fair for me to come back with
the actual facts because i think this is
an example of what you're talking about
where people come up with
an argument to justify something that
actually is nothing to do with economics
or tell me your paternalist efficiency
i'm not paternalistic at all i think
people should have choice my my issue is
that people on low incomes don't have a
choice they're caught into a food cycle
that is feeding them food that leads to
cancer diabetes depression to miserable
existences you have kids going to
hospitals to have their teeth taken out
because they're eating so much sugar
this food is um cheap food sure but it
doesn't give them any nutrition it's not
good food i mean do you like good food
do you like delicious food i love eating
i'm a chef my business is to cook
delicious food you know oaxaca
my restaurants were put out there to try
and have accessible food for all that's
delicious and actually when i went to
mexico that's what i fell in love with
the country because there although now
it's the most peace country in the world
there's a whole nation of food on any of
people on any income who love food and i
feel that that
good food should not be for people who
just have afford can afford it it should
be for everyone and i think my issue is
that people on low incomes do not have
access to fresh fruit and vegetables
they're only eating this food that is
killing them and that's not right i'm
going to come back to but just um before
we
leave your argument chris um
i wonder
you can say that you know
the cost we can argue about these
precise costs but there are costs
associated with poor eating habits and
obesity and so on
if we don't do something about all of
that and do it now rather than sometimes
never never um how do we ever get
to the low tax paradise that i know
you favor
um well because we're still we'll have
to be paying you know gazillions uh for
the nhs well you you don't have to have
an nhs you could have uh private
healthcare insurance and so on so that
you would still be paying health care
but you wouldn't be paying through the
through the tax system at the moment
we're paying 12 of gdp um on on health
care in this country one in eight pounds
and it's going to go up it will go up
everywhere and it's not going up because
of people smoking and being obese it's
going up because we have an aging
society and nobody has a plan of how to
deal with this problem and it's not just
healthcare it's also obviously pensions
right and other welfare benefits the
these these two areas of government
expenditure healthcare and pensions are
going up all the time because we have an
aging society that is what is going to
bankrupt the nhs if anything could and
nothing actually could in practice is
the slogan but that is a major financial
problem sucking money out of everything
else but that is the real time bomb that
we're facing is how we're going to deal
with a society in which in a few years
time you're going to have the average
person
has probably been out of work in various
respects whether in education or retired
for longer that they're in work why
should they be out of work just because
they're i mean
but but our retirement age is going up
right now it's currently right that's
that's the only answer is to keep
putting your assignment agent but lots
of people take pleasure in working
longer they do but there's you know
there's a lot of people who work in
factories or postman or partners in neo
their bodies are knackered by the time
they get to 65. let alone seven so then
they have a non-economic contribution
society which might be volunteering in
their local youth center but that's not
easy but let's let's
let's just stick to today's uh dilemma
let me
ask you thomasina um
is the burden of your case
a little bit maybe not paternalistic but
not trusting people to make good choices
look
the fast food industry or the ultra
processed food industry is designed it's
a perfect blend of sugar fats and salts
that i can't resist because i like all
other humans have been evolved over
thousands of years to not be able to
resist this perfect blend of fat and
sugar and salt that makes it totally
delicious so if i go into a retailer and
find a bog off on my favorite chocolate
bar not only will i buy it but i'll eat
both chocolate bars on the same day even
though i did not want to because it's
kind of irresistible
but because i can afford to also buy
fresh fruit and vegetables because i
have a kitchen with more than just the
microwave i have time to cook it then i
may also have access to cooking eating
great food and because i've been
educated to do so but you know that you
can make that choice and so does every
adult person no they don't they they
absolutely do not have that choice
because they can't afford it and you
know i'm a trustee of chefs in schools
it's a brilliant charity that puts chefs
into school kitchens and transforms the
way kids eat now those kids in those
schools who are on really low incomes
who qualify for free school meals they
love the food we give them we're talking
about fresh fruit and vegetables
vegetarian two or three times a week
it's such delicious food it's home
cooked it's 50 pence per meal per day
cheaper than the mass contract cage was
before it's doing them good and they
love it and the chefs and the schools
are heroes so why can't those kids have
access yeah but
the mother the mother you referred to in
liverpool yeah doesn't have time to go
to chef's school she doesn't have time
to think about these things she has two
three children and she needs to get them
fed and this is a easy way to do so
uh
at the moment
uh with the money she has surely
she is uh has to make her judgment for
herself rather than having the choice
taken away from her well for for sort of
not taking choice away but but let me
just go back to your first point so
we have school food standards in this
country 80 of secondary schools aren't
meeting them so she would love her local
school to feed her kids proper food
because that might be the only hot meal
of the day that they get there because
she might have two jobs and not be able
to cook at night but the fact is we're
failing them because the government
can't be bothered to and just and the
governors of all these schools they
can't be bothered to enforce the tool
for standards which would be brilliant
if we could and it's affordable so
that's a really good economy of scale
and it's a neat way to give people fresh
fruit and vegetables just
nothing nothing against you know
improving standards of school meals at
all i think that's perfectly reasonable
paternalism when you're dealing with
children i would say i mean i broadly
agree with what you say there
but in actual fact healthy food is is
not expensive the supermarkets can't
give a lot of the vegetables uh away
it's actually very cheap and there's not
really any such thing as a food desert
in this country there might be some in
america but thus the vast majority of
people in this country buy supermarket
food when you go to supermarkets there's
fruit and vegetables everywhere the
problem is people this is what you're
saying i think people can't cook it or
they don't have the time to cook it you
should talk to any of the youngsters who
work for bite back which is another
brilliant charity where they are begging
they're begging governments to legislate
and not only they begging people to
legislate because they get targeted on
their smartphones on television and it's
always junk food because that's where
the profit lies no one targets them to
eat more fresh fruit and vegetables
there are millions of pounds of
advertising spent on on targeting junk
food to youngsters because that's what
gives people profit people know what an
apple tastes like they know what banana
tastes like we've had the change for
life program millions of pounds spent
eat more fruit and veg for eight five a
day everybody knows all these things
everyone knows fruit and veg is good for
you and it's also cheap the trouble is
most people including myself cannot make
much of a decent meal out of a bit of
rice or pasta and vegetables it doesn't
taste great and also not everybody is
bothered about food as you are you're
clearly you're you're in the restaurant
business you're
very passionate about food i'm not
particularly quite honestly the less
time i have to spend cooking meal the
better and there's lots of people like
like that and it's interesting i think
that a lot of food campaigners do happen
to be from the restaurant business jamie
oliver the most obvious one through
leith um
they're passionate about what people eat
and they rather disapprove of what
people like me
i don't it's just people i have i am
absolutely i mean food is about pleasure
so whatever gives people pleasure is
great it's when people do not have a
choice so it's not only youngsters who
are begging not to be targeted in their
smartphones and on on television with
these these junk food adverts it's also
the retailers so i spoke to mike lewis
two weeks ago at a food conference he is
at he was the ex-ceo of tesco's the axio
of sainsbury's said the same even the
ceo of greg's have all said give us
regulation because we know that the food
we're giving people is not as healthy it
should be it contains virtually no
nutrition a lot of it
lacking in fiber i mean the amount of
fiber in our diets has plummeted over
the last 50 years that's one of the
things that is making us so ill they are
begging for regulation because they can
only make amends to their recipes and
their recipes and what they sell if
other people do too because otherwise
there's not a level playing field okay
it may not entirely sound like it but i
i can see some a bit of common ground
here first of all you both actually
agree that healthy food good thing and
that actually it doesn't have to be
expensive i think we both agree about
that what i think you may um not quite
agree with behavior and to teach them
better habits so let's see if we can
find some ways uh that we might uh agree
about that um chris what what about this
issue i know you say you can't be
bothered but actually you probably could
be bothered if you um if somebody showed
you a way of making a healthy meal
quickly
yeah maybe maybe i mean i don't know how
unhealthy my meals are i get a jar of
some sauce and mix it in with some meat
and put some rice or pasta in it yeah
okay go get
can can you give
chris a little life lesson here because
i think
well i mean you know i've been cooking
since i was six so yeah i love food i'm
motivated by greed i think
and i guess i guess my difference is i
think good food can also be nutritious
um like delicious food can be nutritious
and my problem is that if we're 50 of
our shopping bars in this country is
ultra processed we're not getting basic
nutrition and that food doesn't satisfy
you so you end up eating more calories
which makes you fatter so it's a kind of
unhealthy food cycle you get yourself
stuck into
i'd also argue that i don't have got
complete common ground the cost of fresh
fruit and vegetables has gone up way
more than the cost of junk food over the
last 30 years and it's kind of that's
completely proven so it's much harder
for people to afford fresh vegetables
and also many people in low incomes have
tiny kitchens they just have a microwave
in them they don't have the time because
they have two or three jobs i mean one
of the things i'd really like to see is
in schools where they have kitchens not
only to adhere to school food standards
but to have canteens and evenings and in
places like liverpool they're doing that
they're having social pantries run by
locals because they don't have access to
fresh fruit and vegetables where they're
getting together and getting old buying
in bulk fresh vegetables and cooking it
for the community people are going to
pay for their food but it's subsidised
because they're about buying it and
volunteers are cooking it we've got to
help people who've got no access to
cooking no knowledge because they
haven't been taught at school it's not
their fault they're not cooking
delicious fresh fruit and vegetables if
they if they have a space dirt they
don't have the time to do it it doesn't
mean they don't want to do it i mean i
feel there's a bit of marie antoinette
about this let them eat crap or cake
because you know he cares about you
you're focusing very much on on the
poorest people in society and i think
that is because it justifies a certain
amount of paternalism oh yeah but how
many people only have a microwave in
their house not that many how many rich
people are obese a lot of them there is
a socio-economic divide with obesity but
it's not it's not actually massive and
amongst men it's actually very small the
reality is that there are
20 others
of rich people are obese okay now that's
not because they can't afford to cook or
they can't afford to buy turnips or what
have you it's because they don't do
enough exercise and they like eating
lots of rich food and probably a lot of
that rich food comes from restaurants by
the way possibly even jamie oliver's
restaurants when he had them
but but i still wonder chris um
it is true that there are a lot of fat
rich people a lot of well exercised rich
people but
um
we know that poverty also leads
over indexes
on obesity and that's to do with food
choices and so on and i just wonder if i
can get both of you to
focus a bit on the issue of behavior and
one of the things i'm hearing i think
it's quite interesting
that is the problem here potentially
um government thomasina is there is
there a possibility that people might
take better advice you talked about we
and education and maybe the problem is
nobody likes to be told what to do by
boris johnson but they might like to be
told what to do by uh thomasina myers i
mean no one likes to be told what to do
full step when you talk to my husband
and you're absolutely actually i don't
like being told what to do but i guess
the point is is that
it's not affordable and you know
people on kids on low incomes are twice
as likely to be obese i mean we know
that my i'm a cha my trusty i'm a
trustee of charity we absolutely know
that um so
yes there are people who are which are
also obese i'm sure they don't want to
be and and yes of course you know junk
food is delicious yeah i'm i'm the first
one to you know succumb if i'm feeling
tired or late i want to eat some some
rubbish it doesn't mean we should make
it impossible for people all incomes not
to eat be able to achieve better food as
well as eating all the treats and the
donuts when they want to we're not
telling people thou shalt not eat that
and i think that's i think you're
slightly miscontrols largely are on junk
food now i know you're saying a ham
cheese sandwich but you can price
promote good food you can price my
healthy food as much as you want and
that would be brilliant because then
people might be able to afford to eat
them better as well as eating the
delicious things as well
i'm wondering chris
the what i'm really trying to get at
here is that one is part of the problem
might be for both of you government and
i know that you know from where you come
from um having ministers telling people
what to do is the kind of worst
nightmare but for example on the green
agenda on environment uh it's proven to
be possible not 100 it's possible for
the private sector to develop offers
that are more green and that have been
taken up and have changed behaviors why
not here
well public health england started an
initiative to try and do exactly that
their magic idea was we're going to have
food reformulation we're going to set
the food industry targets are reducing
calories by 20 and sugar by 20 and salt
salt they've been doing for 20 years or
so and somehow we're just going to get
the calories out of the food but it's
going to be the same food and people
won't notice and they'll just keep
eating the same amount and they'll
consume 20 fewer calories absolutely
ludicrous kind of cloud cuckoo land idea
um and the food companies to be fair did
have a go at it and it didn't make any
difference but people were just switched
from the the reformulated brands and
started buying
a different brand that wasn't
reformulated because people still have
agency people are still sovereign and it
will still they can still spot they're
easily spot when something doesn't taste
as nice where you try to put in some
saccharine instead of sugar the food
industry would love to produce low
calorie food that tastes delicious
they've been trying for decades it is
the holy grail of the food industry they
would clean up if they could make
yogurts with you know eighty percent
fewer calories or whatever regulated
chocolate without sugar
well it's not being regulated that's why
so there's no level playing field as i
said not regularly dave lewis the idea
is insane you can't do it nobody will
buy these products why why wouldn't they
buy them because that's disgusting
are you saying that good food has to
taste disgusting it's just not true you
can't take the sugar out of chocolate
bars or sweets
this is what public health we're trying
to do look no one's wanting to take
sugar out of chocolate bars
that's ridiculous the whole point of
chocolate should be a treat the point is
is what we're doing is we're serving the
meals that people are eating every day
the ultra processed food that's making
50 of our shopping bar that's your
everyday food it's got no fiber it's got
no goodness it's got no nutrition you
can easily produce delicious tasting
food that happens to also be good for
you and that's what the campaign is
about it's not do you not think the food
industry might have thought of this idea
you know there are there are sixty
percent of the population overweight
probably most of them would quite like
to lose a bit of weight i could do with
losing a stone myself if there was
something that tasted identical or even
better in your okay but with fewer
calories why wouldn't everybody be
buying it because it's more expensive
and there's less profit in it now it's
going to be more expensive
of course it is fresh fruit and
vegetables cost more when i talk about
fresh fruit vegetables we're talking
about reformulating existing products so
reformulating so so just to be clear
um
you would still like the government to
uh stop the bog offs and you you would
you agree with william hague that this
is what they've done is morally
reprehensible it's totally more weapons
because you can price promote and help
people when it comes to afford food i've
got to do that and do you think uh
waste of time now possibly a waste of
time ever forever yeah it should be
ditched for good i mean they've delayed
this for one year because of the cost of
living yes
that's been that's been their
justification and you can see it's
really bad at optics this is supposed to
come in october when inflation is
predicted to be about 10 it would be
terrible optics for the tory government
to be telling people we're gonna uh stop
you having access to these food
discounts at a time when inflation's
very high but it's not going to be any
better in october 2023 or it won't be
much better by then there will always be
cost of living problems and we shouldn't
exacerbate them okay well it feels to me
like we have a small amount of common
ground which is everybody should eat
healthy food if they can
uh you started actually by agreeing that
it could be less expensive but then
disagreed about that uh it's clear that
it's going to be difficult but what i
think you do both agree is it would be
good if we could change people's
behavior but we're not quite sure who
the agent is personally um i think i am
i've got to say i think this is a place
where government can
send a message and it can to some extent
change behavior we'll see in a year's
time whether that is true
if i'm wrong
bog off won't be one ever come back but
anyway thank you both very much for a
lively discussion um stay with us anna
botting will have all of today's news
coming up after the break
[Music]